a sharp story uh about homelessness in
this country this is a massive issue all
over the place and it's often coupled
with public fear related to crime and
with good reason since 2015 there's been
a massive 35 increase in the number of
people who are sleeping or camping
outside this is a so-called unsheltered
population of homeless and it turned
these are people who turn into tents
they turn to tarps to boxes to cars
public transportation and to understand
why some people choose the streets even
when a public shelter is available we
talk to a man who was sleeping on a
bench as recently as 2019 and another
who is now in his car
and while everyone agrees that more
housing is what is needed in the long
term the question for many of these
mostly Democratic Mayors and governors
is what do we do with the people on the
streets right now
it's getting harder and harder to ignore
all you have to do is uh walk to work
drive to work and you see homeless
people all scattered all over the place
a source of Heartache or frustration for
just about everyone it's difficult to
walk on that side of the street when
there's a homeless encampment the
question is how do we help the more than
000 people living on the streets in this
country and while lots of local leaders
have promised a fix none have gone quite
as far as New York city mayor Eric Adams
you can't put a Band-Aid on a cancerous
sore
he's not only launched an effort to
clear tents and other structures he's
also stepped up interventions on the
subway pushing people towards what he
says are supportive and voluntary
Services there is no dignity to living
on the street but then came a policy of
involvement voluntary removals allowing
a police officer to take into custody a
person who appears to be mentally ill
and displays an inability to meet basic
living needs even when no recent
dangerous act has been observed if
severe mental illness is causing someone
to be unsheltered and a danger to
themselves we have a moral obligation to
help them get the treatment and care
they need how do you feel about what the
mayor has done
Psy
Donna Lieberman is director of the New
York branch of the American civil
liberties Union what the mayor is doing
is
throwing more police at a problem that
requires a Public Health Solution Adams
announced his plan which includes
transport to a hospital for psychiatric
evaluation after a series of
high-profile crimes police say a woman
was shoved onto the tracks including
killings in New York and Los Angeles
that homeless man ran in and apparently
started attacking them at random with a
knife where the suspects themselves were
homeless men with a history of mental
illness it's such a high-stakes and
delicate call the line between somebody
who is free and just having a bad day
and someone who is a imminent danger to
themselves and others sometimes the
first evidence is the actual act of
violence well who's in the best position
to make the Judgment call is it police
or is it the public health system is it
medical folks and I think it's medical
folks while mayor Adams declined our
request for an interview in a statement
he pointed out the city is expanding
capacity at medical facilities while
also boosting crisis services and
Behavioral Health Emergency teams hey
I'm Tony how's everything on one of the
last cold days of winter we met Shams de
Baron in Harlem not far from where he
used to sleep which spot was you I would
be right here in years past he might
have been somebody flagged for removal
and evaluation by mayor Adams move on
this now instead he's become one of the
mayor's biggest allies I'm not
comfortable with seeing my people out
here like this I want to do something
about it yeah you know it's easy when
you never live this experience to think
it's okay to be able to say that that
box is that person's home I don't think
it's okay and so my goal and I know the
mayor's goal is to say you know we're
going to do something about this we're
going to get these people out we're
going to try to stabilize their lives
and ultimately we want to get them
housing I'm Tony he wanted us to meet
Cornelius Parker better known around
here as magnificent you used to live
right here right here right there was
born down the block not long ago Parker
lost his job and then his home so where
are you sleeping now I'm gonna sleep
right here in my car you sleep in your
car sleeping please and uh what's your
plan for getting back on your feet well
I'm trying to trying to find housing for
now like so many people here in New York
and elsewhere he chooses the streets
even when shelters are available and
shelters are not safe
to work in the shelf that vintage shelf
where you see stabbings and it's not
safe if you lost your vehicle and you
had to sleep on the street you would
choose the street I would choose the
street I'd be a lot safer than the
shelter than the shelter that's how the
baron once felt as well I didn't trust
anybody so I wasn't looking for services
I was comfortable where I was at but I
went from what have been mild depression
to severe depression wow and fortunately
I thought about my children and I said I
gotta get some help he got it walking
himself into a mental health facility
and now he wants others to benefit from
that very same sort of care even if it
means the hand of government has to get
them there either way there is at least
agreement on help more is needed not
having nearly enough housing for people
who need housing with Support Services
that's the real shame that's the real
crime that's what's undermining the
Dignity of too many New Yorkers who are
vulnerable and forced to live on the
streets we need serious Federal
intervention in this otherwise we're
going to see a lot more lives lost to
homelessness we're going to see a lot
more people
um dealing with trauma and mental
illness and substance abuse and it's
just going to create a bad situation for
all of us
I think we can all agree it's a bad
situation to Baron came off the streets
in 2019 after he accepted treatment for
uh his depression also his drinking and
he he credits that Intervention which he
volunteered for was uh saving his life
but you know we mentioned a personal
connection I have to this story uh it's
my own father uh for uh much of 1989 and
1990 off and on in the depths of his own
addiction his own mental health issues
he was sleeping under the I-95 overpass
in Miami by the Miami River there I
visited the location with him what's
interesting on this question of forced
care with people on the streets right
now I talked to my dad about it last
night he would have resisted somebody
coming up to him and saying you got to
move out of here and get into treatment
or some sort of other service even
though the people that love you want you
to do this he would have resisted it but
as a family member I would have been all
in favor of it and so I mean as there
lies The Dilemma there's a dilemma like
in The Wider Human family here we see
these people suffering
we want them to have help they don't
want it at what point is it mandatory
yeah they don't want it or maybe they
don't think it's necessary and now
you're talking about a forceful removal
of somebody that is unsheltered yeah did
your father have an answer if he says
listen I would have resisted I don't
know what you do if you try to help
somebody and they don't want to be
helped there is no answer yeah I don't
know what the answer is uh he said he
would have resisted and violently he did
not want to go until you talk to the man
named magnificent maybe this is naive on
my part it never occurred to me that
they would think the street is safer
than a shelter that never occurred to me
that's very common in New York uh and
and I don't know a lot about the shelter
system but I heard that repeatedly from
multiple people that it's a tough
situation in there Tony that was a
really good piece yes thanks guys